[Musique]
bienvenue paris saclay tv c'est votre
rendez vous aujourd'hui nous célébrons
une date anniversaire 10 ans dix ans
déjà que votre territoire se transforme
il suffit de parcourir le plateau de
saclay pour s'en rendre compte
une date anniversaire est donc un cadeau
à la hauteur de l'événement une
exposition xxl cet artiste contemporain
cette regard sur une décennie de
mutations vous allez découvrir leurs
oeuvres dans cette émission on vous
emmène ensuite à la découverte de la
résidence rosalind franklin ce complexe
étudiants se situe au coeur du quartier
de l'école polytechnique
nous irons aussi à la friche de talent
est c'est ainsi qu'elle était surnommé
aujourd'hui elle se transforme elle
commence à être aménagé
vous pourrez ainsi profiter d'un grand
parc où vous profiterez de la
biodiversité du lieu tout a été fait
pour protéger les espèces et enfin l'art
s'installe dans sa version monumental
avec adm unités du vivant une oeuvre
signée de pascal mazille nous avons
rencontré l'artiste
il va dévoiler cette oeuvre qui est
assez impressionnante je dois le dire
et notre agenda et bien vous le savez
c'est à la fin d'émission
disant cela fait dix ans que paris
saclay se transforme dans le cadre de la
loi portant sur le grand paris voilà qui
méritait bien une exposition xxl cet
artiste contemporain nous livrent leur
regard sur paris saclay ils ont arpenté
le territoire ils s'en sont inspiré pour
créer des oeuvres que vous pouvez d'ores
et déjà découvrir en ligne qui sont
ensuite exposés nous avons rencontré le
commissaire de cette exposition paysages
paris saclay il s'agit de marque
partouche on m'a proposé d'être
commissaire d'une exposition au fait
t'es marquer l'anniversaire des dix ans
de l'établissement public de paris
saclay et d'emblée le commanditaire les
interlocuteurs que j'ai eus ont accepté
l'idée non pas de faire une exposition
traditionnelle ou choisir et des oeuvres
déjà existantes
mais ce qui est assez rare et assez
audacieux de passer commande un certain
nombre d'artistes établis d'été à partir
d'un choix d'une première proposition
d'artistes j'ai fait
l'idée c'était demandé à chaque artiste
de réaliser des oeuvres faites
spécialement pour l'exposition et en
prenant en compte la spécificité de ce
que recouvrait l'ensemble du territoire
sous l'appellation l'établissement
public d'aménagement paris sacré en
discutant un peu en regardant un peu cet
ensemble que je connaissais mal je
connaissais par ailleurs mais mal ce qui
m'a paru évident de suite c'est de faire
une exposition autour de la notion
paysage au sens large du terme avec la
clé trois ans de paysages paysage humain
paysage urbain paysages naturels et
ensuite l'idée c'était de multiplier les
regards de multiplier les points de vue
et à trois photographes
enfin trois artistes qui utilise la
photographie un plasticien qui est un
artiste numérique qui fait des camps
environnement numérique des
installations
numérique un peintre dessinateur
sculpteur installateurs et un
dessinateur peintre tous les artistes
ont visité le territoire l'ont arpenté
et de l'idée c'était que chacun remonte
de cette traversée des oeuvres des
points de vue qu'est ce qui les
intéressait qu'est-ce qui retenait
qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient frappé et donc
non seulement ils ont tous joué le jeu
mais ils ont été très généreux puisque
au bout du compte on aura à peu près 70
heures donc très très grand format de
forme appelée moyens qui vont être
exposées dans théoriquement cette ville
sur l'ensemble du territoire il y aura
sans doute aussi une étape à paris
c'est un complexe étudiant qui vient
tout juste d'être livrés au coeur du
quartier de l'école polytechnique
distingué par les cartes d'argent
catégorie habitat en novembre dernier la
résidence rosalind franklin que vous
découvrez et signé par le groupement
brûlures et bas au queen's voilà qui
vient augmenter l'offre de logements
étudiants sur le campus
l'agent sous terre donc on a été lauréat
avec social agence beaucoup du projet de
résidences étudiantes à parking
réversible public à palaiseau sur le
plateau de saclay s'agit d'une résidence
étudiante 292 chambres 206 du logement
est associé un parking parkings publics
qu'ils n'ont la demande était d'être
réversible
donc il s'agit d'un programme hybride
mixte qui couple ces deux entités
programmatique
la particularité de ce projet c'est
vraiment leur imbrication programmatique
donc une imbrication horizontale avec
une partie du parking en superstructure
sur deux niveaux et au dessus les
logements étudiants qui viennent au
dessus de ce parti l'organisation elle
est assez simple avec un grand
rez-de-chaussée plutôt très ouvert très
libre qui laisse passer les bus qui
accueille finalement tous les espaces
collectifs ou à chacun des programmes
donc des salles de travail des espaces
de services pour la résidence
l'accueil de la résidence également
des commerces et également tous les
espaces d'accueil pour le parking une
des questions qui étaient importantes
c'était la question de la réversibilité
de ce projet dont comment anticiper le
futur avec la question du parking la
question des stationnements de la
voiture donc comment faire finalement
ces équipements un peu de la modernité
qui sont souvent cachés en faire un lieu
qui soit agréable ou en tout cas qu'on
puisse repenser sa fonctionnalité
dans un futur proche ou lointain
notamment avec l'arrivée du futur métro
sur le plateau le précaire d'argent 2020
je pense qu'il nous a été remis du fait
de cette hybridité programmatique
il est assez riche en fait de faire des
bâtiments qu'ils soient hybrides que des
bâtiments peut-être uniquement de
logement peuvent être enrichis d'un
autre programme et c'est ce que montre
cette opération et je pense que les
caire nous a récompensés pour ça c'était
gratifiant pour l'ensemble de nos
partenaires techniques et également pour
nos deux maîtres d'ouvragé mille et une
vies habitat pour la résidence étudiante
et le pps pour le parking public
réversible
[Musique]
elle était surnommée la friche de thales
situé sur la partie sud du quartier de
corbeil ville
il a été décidé de reconvertir cette
ancienne friche et de l'intégrer au
projet urbain la zac de corneville est
pleinement opérationnel les bâtiments de
thales ont été détruits vous allez
bientôt pouvoir profiter du parc est
aussi redécouvrir ce château que vous
voyez derrière moi nous avons rencontré
les chefs de projets de le pps la vague
de coeur de ville à cheval entre les
communes d'orsay et de saclay est situé
entre le quartier de l'école
polytechnique à palaiseau et de quartier
de moulins entre juifs et arabes
nous sommes ici dans la partie sud du
quartier de khor de ville de terrains
sur lesquels nous sommes situés étaient
communément appelée la triche thales en
effet notre priest à l'aise y avait
installé des bureaux et de laboratoires
même le château que nous voyons derrière
nous avait été transformée en espace de
travail pour l'entreprise
aujourd'hui le désamiantage et la
démolition des bâtiments de bureaux est
achevé et il a été décidé d'utiliser
cette friche dans le cadre du projet
urbain
le terrain est à présent après
accueillir de nouveaux usages le projet
porté par le pea par isaac et consiste à
valoriser l'emplacement privilégié de ce
site en connexion directe avec la vallée
au travers du poteau boisé sur la partie
ouest de la friche un grand parc sera
aménagé il aura vocation à être utilisé
par tous les usagers du plateau et les
habitants de la vallée à l'est du
château un quartier de logements et
d'équipements sera créé et bénéficiera
de vue privilégiée sur les châteaux le
coteau et la vallée
pour les dossiers réglementaires de la
zac de cordes ville le diagnostic
environnemental a identifié plusieurs
enjeux écologiques notamment la présence
d'espèces patrimoniales et d'habitat
intéressant pour la biodiversité
le site est particulièrement intéressant
pour les chiroptères les chauves-souris
neuf espèces ont été identifiées sur
l'intégralité du site notamment au
niveau des caves les dépendances du
château ccaf seront conservés et
notamment les entrées seront aménagés
pour connaître chiroptères de continuer
à les fréquenter et empêché l'accès du
public
une attention particulière sera portée à
l'éclairage nocturne notamment pour
réduire son impact sur ces espèces la
châtaigneraie un site remarquable
notamment par la présence de gros arbres
anciens avec de nombreuses cavités
ses qualités sont utilisés par beaucoup
d'espèces notamment des oiseaux et les
chiroptères et dans le cadre du projet
d'aménagement un espace public sera créé
ici et la plupart des arbres seront
conservés en les mettant à distance des
principaux cheminement
le mur d'enceinte de domaine de cordes
ville est en meulière il fait environ
600 m de long et c'est un habitat
favorable pour le lézard des murailles
une espèce protégée
également présente sur le site et dans
le cadre du projet aménagement plusieurs
passages seront créés au sein de ce mur
et les parties qui seront détruites
seront reconstitués juste à côté
enfin la renaturation d'une grande
partie de la friche en parc public
permettra d'améliorer la biodiversité du
secteur grâce à l'augmentation d'environ
700 arbres
[Musique]
l'art dans la ville c'est aussi cette
toute nouvelle sculpture l'adn du vivant
comme un clin d'oeil à l'adn des
étudiants de l'école normale supérieure
de paris sa clique juste là à côté
nous avons rencontré l'artiste pascal
mazille
[Musique]
cette sculpture qui est donc derrière
moi puisque nous venons de l'installer
est une réponse cultural à une demande
que m'avait faite
l'établissement public d'aménagement du
plateau de saclay pour accompagner sur
le plan artistique
l'ensemble des écoles d'ingénieurs
plutôt scientifique et même toute
scientifique qui s'installe petit à
petit sur ce plateau c'est incroyable
plateau que ce soit supélec bien sûr
centrale nst qui est juste derrière nous
et d'autres
il m'a été demandé travailler sur un
thème de la science et j'ai donc
souhaité travailler sur le thème qui est
derrière moi qui ai l'adn qui pour moi
est la molécule la grande molécule phare
de la biologie donc de la science du
vivant
cette molécule semble jaillir de la du
globe terrestre qui est juste en dessous
est en fait la métaphore est la suivante
c'est que la composition chimique de la
terre a bien évidemment déterminée de la
composition chimique de la grande
molécules du vivant qu'est l'adn que
l'on retrouve dans tout le vivant
d'où le thème de la sculpture qui
s'appelle adn unités du vivant puisque
cet adn on va le retrouver dans tout ce
qui est vivant
alors il s'agit d'une sculpture qui est
une pièce unique que j'ai fait pour
cette installation ici l air est en
bronze
elle a été coulé par une fonderie dans
l'est de la france va fonder deux
royaumes et elle est donc de quatre
mètres de haut
en plus de son socle en béton un socle
en béton que j'ai souhaité
voir ressembler à celui de l'année ce
qui est juste à côté pour créer une
sorte d'unité visuel dernier petit clin
d'oeil peut-être à cette sculpture tout
en haut il y a comme une sorte quand on
regarde de côté il ya une sorte de
sphère en vide qui rappelle ou qui
évoque la lune pour pouvoir observer la
lune il faut l'adn du cerveau des
humains qui permet de comprendre ce que
sont les astres voilà donc il ya tout un
tas de symboles qui viennent se greffer
les uns sur les autres ou s'enrichir les
uns sur les autres
voilà ce que j'ai souhaité faire et je
suis vraiment reconnaissant à le pea et
à la ville de gif bien sûr de ma va
confier un tel projet
[Musique]
et maintenant notre agenda beaucoup de
rendez vous culturels dans les semaines
à venir avec déjà sept expositions xxl à
dont on vous a parlé exposition
anniversaire paris saclay paysage 7
regard d'artiste sur le territoire vous
l'avez découverte dans cette émission
vous pouvez aller la découvrir sur le
site
paris tire et saclay tirer paysage
pourrait faire de la musique avec un
concert qui met le jazz et musique
classique
la violoniste fiona monbet est
accompagné par pierre cussac à
l'accordéon un duo créatif qui revisite
avec bonheur stravinsky gershwin
bernstein si la pandémie le permet
rendez vous est donc pris le 1er mars au
waldorf astoria versailles le 2 mars à
17h venez réfléchir à la méthanisation
des territoires ou comment mettre en
place des énergies renouvelables
traitement des bio déchets et
agriculture durable
cette réunion se déroule en webinaire et
c'est gratuit plus d'informations sur
notre site
et allez on va y croire on va se
projeter au mois de juin on y croit à la
fête des artistes elle aura bien lieu
les 5 et 6 juin à gif tous les artistes
plasticiens de la commune qu'ils soient
professionnels ou amateurs sont invités
à participer
vous avez jusqu'au 19 février pour vous
inscrire et voilà c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau paris saclay tv d'ici là
restez informé sur le site pap.fr sur tv
78 et surtout surtout prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]